hey what's up guys thanks for tuning in
to are you garbage please make sure you
go
subscribe to the youtube channel that
way you get the videos as they come out
yeah do it welcome to another exciting
edition of
are you garbage the show where you find
out if your favorite comedians are
classy individuals
or absolute trash now
here are your hosts kevin ryan and
h foley hey everybody out there
bon jovi edition to everybody's favorite
new podcast
this is ru garbage it's a show we sit
down with your favorite comedian
and we found out they grew up classy or
if they're absolute trash
i'm your host age foley coming at you on
a beautiful day
down here in totty's basement she just
got done shoveling out the car
so let me tell you something don't park
in that [ __ ] spot or you're gonna get
[ __ ] maced i'm just telling you right
the chairs out that's exactly right
don't come around here looking for
parking okay
take your [ __ ] to center city with
the rest of the bozos my co-host
is coming at you from right next to me
folks i got a quick question for you
who's tripping down the streets of the
city smiling at everyone he sees
who's reaching out to capture the moment
everybody knows
it's kippy kevin james ryan everybody
you are really taking swings in
a new intro this kid's good
is going for [ __ ] holy [ __ ] guys
what's up thanks so much for tuning in
as always please make sure you rate
review subscribe on itunes
full video available on youtube those
numbers are true to [ __ ] roof
also uh patreon.com you can sign up you
get bonus uh episodes of ayg
you get episodes of hard feelings which
is me and foley behind the curtains
chopping it up a little bit
him calling me bald me calling him fat
for an hour it's a good time
high brow content and hey don't forget
to you can download the patreon app
make it easier for you to consume the
content sure we went over that in the
morning meeting
and uh every month we pl with the top
tier patrons we play uh
an episode of ayg you guys ask us
questions we ask you questions a good
[ __ ] time get involved baby yes sir
thank you so much
nice big shout out to our producer
extraordinaire the [ __ ] magic man
now you see him now you don't that's
right ladies and gentlemen we call him
t-bone but his mommy named him
toby mcmullen everybody oh [ __ ] what up
boys
hey buddy yeah i'm telling you right now
you move a chair in chicago
when somebody got dibs that's a good way
to get your tires slashed yeah oh dude
if you
if you steal someone's someone to shovel
you've got a good talking too you'll get
a [ __ ]
i mean your windows will be smasher
caught your car will be keyed up north
side of the south side you don't move
that chair bro
there you go take that [ __ ] up to
rosemont with the rest of the hippies up
there
okay this is old town chicago i'm just
fixing in here a little bit anybody else
fixing well i'm quaking a little warm
i know what it is we got a [ __ ] hot
guest gun
i got a hater we got a little [ __ ]
star power in this dump we thought he
was having a stroke
we could not be more excited to have our
incredibly special guest here with us
today he is a very funny
stand-up comedian podcaster and actor
you know him from the hit
digital series tires seen him on matt
and shane's secret podcast
he has a brand new animated digital
series out right now on patreon
called show brood it's a good-looking
kid
he's got a real real rich kid hat on
[Laughter]
you gotta have money shallow hat gotta
have this guy's been to a regatta
i'm telling you that right now give it
the [ __ ] up for mr chris
o'connor everybody nice to be here yeah
philly kid
yeah philly comedy scene philly comedy
started out
yeah yeah started out in philly was down
in philly for a while
but you're a connecticut kid or
something yeah i grew up outside in i
grew up
in connecticut yeah i grew up in
greenwich actually that's like that's
cause
connecticut's either like really [ __ ]
dicey or nice no it's nice
it's nice but i like it yeah i don't
know it was it was
it connected granite just like a big
town so there's like there's like
crazy rich people and then there's kind
of like where we were sure
um you got a little bit of cash though i
personally
personally haven't had any cash no no my
parents are doing okay
but they're also like yeah it's not
crazy like if you were to go to my house
you'd be like oh this is fine
yeah really yeah no boats no
no kayaks no my uh x dude i grew up
i grew up probably like yeah tell us the
whole deal i grew up like
literally 200 feet probably from the
water i think i swam in it
eight times a body of water long island
sound
oh [ __ ] yeah yeah you can't go in i
could like
almost see it from my house but i yeah
never went in it it just like i don't
know my
it's it's i've been like i didn't
realize i even
lived in like a beach town until i moved
to philly i don't know if greenwich is a
beach town
it is oh it is it's a beach it's like
yeah i've never heard of anybody been
like i haven't had a
greenwich to go surfing it ain't a beach
town it's on the water i'll give you
that
listen me and the bird we go up to uh
greenport which would be across the
across the sound from you and uh the one
time we went up there we stayed at this
place
uh that was on the water and it's not
really it had water damage
caught a flood in sandy which ruined all
my expensive clothes
hence the lawsuit i have going with this
establishment
my knee still hurts um the it's very
rocky it's not in
i i would like a yeah i would have never
dove into that water either dude
yeah i mean that's how i remember it i
remember like because they used to tell
us that after it rained you couldn't go
in it for like three days
why just yeah yeah yeah
gets churned up yeah long island sound
yeah yeah like i was i was always under
the impression it was like disgusting
so this is out so you grew up outside of
greenwich no
it was in greenwich in greenwich proper
yeah yeah the property value
even if the house is in that yeah yeah
it's got to be it's got to be over a
mill
yeah the property property's worth a lot
yeah sure yeah
but yeah it's again it's just not that
it's i don't know it's like
it's like if someone comes to new york
and they go into like a tiny little
apartment you're like this is two
thousand dollars a month yeah yeah
that's true i think you'd be more like
geesh you're paying that much
you paid that much for this [ __ ] what
did your parents do
growing up uh my mom's nurse and my
dad's an engineer
okay locomotives no bridges oh
holy [ __ ] did he do any big britches or
anything i would recognize
he did uh
yeah he did the turnpike expansion wait
wait what
yeah what turnpike the new jersey turns
well there's multiple turnpikes i mean
no in my house there's only one term i'm
getting your house
it was the turnpike okay he's pretty but
he's dumb
he's got good shoulders with no head
his kids got surfer bro dude you were
like the way you responded i felt like i
[ __ ] up i'm like what uh
i'm like is there more well you're you
you live between philly and new york
pennsylvania
pennsylvania isn't there a connecticut
[Laughter]
hold on a second your dad was one of the
engineers that designed the new jersey
turnpike
no no no he didn't design it he was a
project manager yeah you like work on it
to make sure it's like
your dad owns new jersey yeah yeah
let me tell you that make sure the
concrete's right yeah yeah yeah
whatever yeah that's pretty [ __ ] cool
because i tell you what out of all the
turnpikes
jersey turnpike is my favorite you know
there's
the most roy rogers per capita see
that's wrong with roy's at grover
cleveland i'm paying attention
to debbie anytime i talk to someone uh
who like lives in like central jersey
and like old people and i tell them that
my dad like worked on that they're like
oh
we love that
get over here the kid's dad did the
turnpike dude you wouldn't believe the
traffic
i do it's a [ __ ] straight shot to new
york you're doing like 90.
yeah dude i i clean liverpool i was i
was one of those
kids that like we were philly trash
right so like
i had been to new york like once or
twice before i moved up to new york
like my mom has been up to new york in
seven or eight years i've been living
here she's been up twice to see me like
she's like new york it might as well be
[ __ ] pluto like
they're just they just don't go up and
uh
i remember the first time i found out
that the the turnpike had a car lane and
then a truck
and an suv my mind was exploded
it was the the most insane thing to me
what do you do you take the you take
care i was always a truck lane guys
because you zip around though you don't
run like fast
furious i like it yeah i like to look
down
yeah yeah i go truck lane every once in
a while i'll go truck lane late at night
sometimes they'll shut down the car lane
really i don't know they gotta like do
some repair on the bridge
on the horn yeah yeah you have some kind
of give it a special easy pass or
something like that
no special privileges now wait a minute
so he helped design the new jersey
turnpike
my parents are watching this right now
and they're going home henry knows a guy
he's kid who designed a new jersey
turnpike
dude foley's just angling for comps on
his road trips dude
can you fix tickets or what no he's the
guy he's a guy he goes down there
and goes like you can build this right
and then the content yeah you got to
make sure that's fine
whatever does he still do it now uh
now he's working on a different job he's
working on uh
some training connecticut throughway
yeah no no he's backing
back in north jersey he's like lived in
jersey for like
eight years or whatever however long
okay um he's on
uh there's some railroad bridge that
they're
repairing there's like they're changing
it from like a raising bridge or a
rotating
thing to a raising bridge or some [ __ ]
yeah damn that's pretty [ __ ] where
you go to school
he went uh he went to worcester poly
tech
in worcester massachusetts
[Laughter]
yeah worcester polytechnic home of the
dark
chi fold then i think i don't know i
think he did he transferred to manhattan
college
that's pretty good there you go yeah he
got jasper's yeah
not bad all right so that engineer mom
nurse pretty good
brothers sisters what's the deal uh yeah
i got an older brother
how old uh he's three years older than
me i feel like he's probably the
successful one yeah he does well
yeah yeah he's like a lawyer he's doing
really well yeah he's doing great
i mean and philly weren't you doing some
kind of production work
yeah i was uh i did like editing for
pharmaceutical
companies so why did i think that your
dad owned a production company
no no i thought he did i thought you
worked for your dad
no in a production company no no my dad
doesn't know we could have just replaced
that
why am i dumb yeah no i
have no no connection to the to that
yeah he's doing [ __ ] rotating bridges
yeah time for hollywood movies
okay all right and what about you did
you go to you went to school went to
college i went to drexel yeah
you did yeah you went to the days yeah
and that's so that's where the
philippines for engineering
uh now just for business or whatever
okay what were you gonna do
what do you mean
[Laughter]
i meant later this afternoon but all
right what was i gonna do i don't know
i was just they accepted me so i went
not a bad school it's a good school you
got
it's into yeah yeah yeah it's a good
school yeah expensive a little bit of
cage a couple of blocks yeah yeah
back in the day was like 40 40 at night
screwing around yeah
well that's why i went to tu baby owls
shout out to them um yeah all right
okay did you go where did you go to
school in philly or now i went to
weidner
university for a couple of weeks
and he does not uh miss an opportunity
to talk about his football career while
he was there
hello and goodbye really he played
football at widener playing a little
ball
really defensive tackle nickel and dime
package yeah told me get a computer
still do you have do you have tape do
you have film
no oh i didn't even think about calling
you on your bluff either let's get some
of the film going
yeah that's it patty i know you're
watching this pull up me picking my nose
on the face
tamale i come around the tunnel okay
let's go yeah they had the cleanest
jersey on that bench
like a tide commercial kid's fresh
all right let's [ __ ] get into it
let's [ __ ] get into it a little bit
here and find out now enough of the
[ __ ] around
let's do some of the basics he's a
suburban kid we can hit him with a
couple of [ __ ] one two threes
um growing up well first of all what was
the name of the street that your parents
house was on
lockwood lockwood what's liquid drive
that's pretty [ __ ] good
that sounds pretty good
[Applause]
i didn't even realize greenwich was like
a really rich town until uh
like high school would you go in you'd
go into you can go into town there's
like a there's like an actual
yeah but like i don't know like all my
friends were all my other
friends were kids whose parents were
like new york transplants as well
like my best friend's house would go
over there there was just like a
pregnant dog in a pool
all the time what the [ __ ] is that i
don't know you're hanging out with our
kids on the wrong side
yeah i don't know anytime people were
like oh greenwich that's fancy i was
like i don't know
they're breeding pit bulls it's a kiddie
pool yeah there's a big fat chocolate
lab just in heat
did you go to a dogs with the nipples i
can't with the nipples on the dogs
it's so gross and they
they don't go away for a while all
chewed on and [ __ ]
get the [ __ ] out of here if you have if
you your dog has them don't invite me
over i'm telling you that now
do you have a dog with nipples no i
would have [ __ ] put him down or open
the door and let him go get the [ __ ] out
of here
strict no nipples
my mom got him taken off just a belly
full of slinkies
did you go to uh private school or
public school public you went to public
yeah yeah
okay yeah okay hey gang let's take a
quick second to talk about the good time
that uncle hank and aunt kippy are
having over there on the stereo app
every thursday night at nine o'clock we
answer
your questions yeah guys we go live
every thursday
it's a good time we just did our first
one there was a couple hundred people in
there big man not too shabby a lot of
great questions it's a fun time we
interact with you guys it's kind of like
an after party of the show type thing
get involved go to www.stereo.com
kevinryan or slash h foley don't forget
the big man
that's right uh and when you sign up we
get to with our beaks a little bit it's
a good time
get involved it's free sign up today
what uh
what grocery store did your parents shop
at big one
uh what was the name it was just like
some it was like a
one in town it's called porcellis oh
local one in town porcelli's in
greenwich probably pretty nice italians
know their way around the market
i'm getting a picture they do i'm
picturing your mom walking out with the
brown paper bag
holding the two like yeah baguette
sticking out maybe some lettuce you know
at the market yet
dude literally like i think my my mom
has tried to make stuff that's like
nice but all my dad wants is like egg
noodles and chicken parmesan
egg noodles a man after my own heart
would you
say just get your garbage uh
yeah i got family i got some garbage
qualities italian background or irish
background irish
100 all irish yeah yeah yeah
what the [ __ ] is that all about that's
[ __ ] dirtball
all i remember yeah it's just we would
yeah that was pretty much it we'd have
tacos
chicken parm pork chops yeah that's
the dry ice cream that's the white trash
wheelhouse right there yeah didn't you
say you've never had a pork chop before
i don't think i've ever had a banana
either not that i can remember i don't
[ __ ] with them
devil dogs devil dogs were big what's it
that's the devil doing the hostess the
drake's kids
yeah it's like two chocolate things yeah
yeah yeah shout out what do you mean
they were big
look at that turnpike a couple dogs in
my house
this is things you gotta respect the egg
noodles all right so
my opinion is starting to shift a little
bit here all right
so where do you get the hat from then
stole it from his brother yeah dude i
don't know
over the summer it's a lake too squam
yeah nothing's adding up the look the
beard you got a nice nike
hoodie on yeah you're wearing you look
you look like a rich guy who's into rock
climbing
yeah no no no no no no he's got that
body he's got the big shoulders like the
functional
yeah you look like you do the stand-up
uh surfboard thing whatever
like you don't make kombucha but you
make money off i couldn't i could i
could totally
i could totally do that i could do that
yeah you look at that you could grow
weak
you do like part of like like even like
the the hoodie you have the hat
you do have like a very uh northeastern
like
uh kind of white like average white guy
vibe yeah like north of philadelphia and
new york there's like a little bit
different like more wilderness a little
bit yeah i you know what i like
you wear cargo shorts for the
functionality a little bit yeah yeah
yeah
yeah what happened was i was over the
summer i went to this lake
it's a dope hat and it's nice and i was
like i was working on that cartoon
like where were you at explain to me
what you mean when you went to the lake
you went to stay there
yeah yeah my family went up there and we
were just like in the woods
so your family goes to a lake house in
the summer yeah
man these are they so connors are
[ __ ] they get you coming and going
i don't know what the [ __ ] do you think
that's fancy or no it can't go either
way
no but we did lake houses too and it's
trash yeah lake housing can be
really fun woods is scary oh dude it's
so scary
but i settled i was i settled in and i
was like it is
scary when it gets quiet at night and
you feel the lights are on in the house
every someone's outside looking this is
yeah it's like if i was gonna kill
someone this is where i would just
exactly off the highway into some little
town find a lightning
back on i'm out dude i think about that
too much yeah the city it's i've always
feel like it's harder to get away with
but even that's [ __ ] i've gotten
carjacked
like around people really in philly yeah
yeah what neighborhood
uh i was in west philly they took the
car oh yeah
yeah yeah i got out of the car like the
guy i was parallel parked
i was all stoned i parallel parked and i
remember i was so
pumped that i had like parallel parks
yeah yeah i was like [ __ ] yeah
and i got his confidence oh and i
i opened the door and i was it was my
friend's car ah
it's actually the best case scenario you
don't get shot and you don't lose oh
dude give me the keys
all right yeah this is literally what
happened i got out of the car and he's
like he's like trying to get shot
tonight how about you give me them keys
and i was so happy now but i was just
like oh
all right let me get my weave out yeah
i literally as i was walking away i was
like oh [ __ ] i left my phone in the car
oh that's the worst part
and i i literally just without think
turner i was like oh hey man i left my
phone in the car can i grab it real
quick
what yeah and he goes yeah all right
probably because that's gp you could at
least track
you know maybe that you know i don't
know i don't think he was thinking too
clearly
but i i called yeah so he was like yeah
call the cops
and i was like all right and i just
called the cops
and then and then the cops came and
picked me up
and just drove around western village
just drove around west philly for a
while and then took me to like 55th and
pine
to that like precinct or whatever we got
out and i just like sat in this hallway
called my friend who was like in air
like flying to california mm-hmm
and i looked i was a rich guy that's a
really that's right
this is the worst part this is the worst
part about people thinking that you have
money
is that everything you say people are
like oh dude i've never heard
anybody refer to it as in the air he was
in air
dude i like if i i i like i don't play
guys oh somebody somebody that's
somebody who
knows somebody with a plane you know
somebody with a plane when you say the
term
what else do you say when someone's like
we're on a plane
and there's a little bit of cake usually
in my family they say they're actually
on the bus
so we can't i can't get a hold of them
oh that's great
so they're in air anytime i see someone
they're like they post on instagram or
something that they're like playing golf
like just like a comic i'm just like
what are you gonna get [ __ ] ripped
for that
yeah yeah i want to take off now that
i've gotten a little older i'm 34.
i feel like i can like i could before
i'd be like post a picture of me golfing
or something i'd be like oh
people are going to [ __ ] think i'm
like some rich [ __ ] [ __ ] you know
one percenter i can't do this
no i'm older i got [ __ ] it i went and
played chip and putt with our good
friend tommy cassidy it was actually a
nice day
it's not bad you snuck on at hole three
and i cut a hole in the fence but i
wouldn't mind doing it either
but back to the carjacking oh yeah stay
on topic here
oh yeah so i called him i left him a
message being like hey like your car's
what kind of car was gone it was an
orange honda element hmm wow that's
terrible
i know yeah the most is also the most
conspicuous car
on earth yeah why would you steal that
one like yeah the color
and the car yeah so be on the lookout
for the cat in the hat
i think it stinks oh man
that was the one where like the doors
open like the four way or whatever
get out of here he said it was orange
right yeah that was i think that was one
of the first ones that had like that
because i see more orange orange is
making a comeback dude
stop with the with the mazda somebody's
doors yeah you look like a [ __ ]
goober yeah it was it was like honda's
answer to the like what was that what's
that
is it chrysler that [ __ ] shitty hmm
what the [ __ ] the pt
cruiser the pregnant roller skate but
out of here with that
dude you are garbage a couple of my
parents friends i love swift up and the
pt cruiser crate
a [ __ ] 09 or whatever it was real
shitty
there's nothing more disgusting than a
like a worn out pt
cruiser yeah they don't have a long
shelf life either
and like the thing is like people think
they're cool that's the worst part
oh man yeah that in the chrysler 600 was
pretty shitty
i don't remember it sounds nice no that
was like the bentley looking yes exactly
garbage they were killing people left
and right too they had a huge blind spot
in them
really i read popular mechanics
sounds like an insurance not many people
know this
one hit me all right all right
let's see what'd you get on the sats big
question
uh 1380.
that guy's in air right there this kid's
a serial killer all right
i don't know what's gold lake house 1300
animated cartoons yeah no i bought a
smart kid i knew you were a smart kid i
always knew you were saying i have my i
have my moments but
yeah i bought this hat when i was i was
like you know what i'm gonna like live
just like in the woods i think and like
make cartoons
when you i would love that yeah yeah so
you don't draw
i mean i would i don't i would do a bad
podcast in the woods
all right all right i can't get it i
can't get it i can't get a [ __ ]
flip man it really is now i forget yeah
i think you say you think you're garbage
or you don't think you're garbage i
think
yeah i got some yeah i think people
would consider me garbage and you said
your parents are both from new york yeah
new york transit yeah bronx yeah all
right so
we covered the grocery store we covered
what do you guys do in the summer you go
did you ever go skiing you got a
beach house you got to leave yeah i'd go
down the shore there was a while we'd go
to the poconos
and then we'd go down the shore yeah
yeah
so you're rich they got yeah my parents
got some cash yeah
there was money growing up and it would
come and go like there was
like oh we got a short house and they're
like oh they rebuilt the car type thing
it was like
it was very back and it was ebbs and
flows for a while where was the family
vacation usually for you guys
uh up to that lake it was yeah yeah it's
a real like
yeah you don't own a property up there
no no no no you're renting a
rent yeah a house or is it like uh yeah
we were
like we did like there was like a little
like community of cottages we did that
for a while for like
for most of the time and then just like
past couple years it's been like a house
what sort of activities
what sort of activities would you do on
the lake uh
we literally just like we would rent a
boat and just go around
pontoon now like a speedboat kind of
thing
yeah yeah yeah that was nice but like
yeah we just like we like water ski
are you a good water skier pretty rich
guy [ __ ] not real
dude water skiing they're not in [ __ ]
nantucket they're at a lake house in the
middle of connecticut or something or
new hampshire yeah they're not that nice
can you drink this like no no definitely
not is there any springs up there it's a
nice it's a nice lake
it's cool it's it is nice it's like that
was like
always the weird thing like we like
growing up it's like we would people
would get
you know people would be pissed if they
like the heat was too high or like a
window was left open or light was left
like it was always like you were getting
[ __ ]
about stuff like we didn't have money
but then anytime you needed something
it was all you could always get it yeah
i was the same way and i was just like i
was talking
this week and i'm like the mic towards
your face yeah i eat the mic a little
bit um
i was uh i was talking about this i'm
like i'm done making them feel like
i'm done with letting them make me feel
bad about spending money on stuff oh
yeah my parents like well that's gonna
be 50 bucks to go out to dinner like
yeah you have it okay
i don't let's go dude yeah i got no
making a large pie
what are we doing i got in a fight with
my mom about christmas presents
like i want i was like i'm going to go
to the mall and find out niece and neph
no needs a nephew like a christmas
present
and uh she was like don't do that
dancing i got one
she had like a batmobile from [ __ ]
five years ago she was like
just give this to him yeah no i'm gonna
go i want to get it then you're the
uncle that tells you you're like sitting
there with yeah
no [ __ ] yeah and she was like she just
like didn't get it that was a big
what are you going to get just shut up
yeah just [ __ ] shut up
sounds like a fun christmas at the end
yeah guys are playing it real cool
dude yeah my mom's getting on my dad too
she like she thinks my dad's like
falling apart
she was like his hearing's gone he's
here and it's literally because
my entire life like that guy designing
my turnpike
my entire life here if my dad was
watching tv
you couldn't get through yeah like dad
dad dad you know you have to like yell
at him my whole life
and now my mom talk tries to talk to him
while he's watching tv and he doesn't
respond and she's like see
he's going it's like hyper focused same
as it's been for 30 years knocking you
out that's choice
yeah yeah yeah it's not a defect man so
a little dysfunction
a little bit of cash lake house the
in-air
it's a lot you guys have a garage
growing up yeah do you have a fridge in
the garage
uh no no garage fridge what kind of cars
are they sure what i'm saying two
fridges
usually yeah the thing is so the idea
bought a second fridge
no so it's like you have a fridge and
then you get a new fridge you move into
a house
and now you have an old fridge and the
trashy thing is well i can't throw out
this perfectly working fridge you put it
in the garage
no one ever buys a new second fridge i
had friends that had two fridges and i
was always like damn
clean living yeah holy [ __ ] you got two
fridges
same guy that was breeding the show
the mini horses yeah
i don't like those little ponies man
they [ __ ] make me sad i don't know
why
um so we got that we got the no garage
pool was there a pool in the house
no no pool no pool damn empty backyard
did you have a pool
yeah see that's above ground it's as
trashy as you can get it's an above
ground and they built a deck
the whole entire size of the backyard
above it so now it's like
it's an above ground in the ground pool
it makes it look like it's in ground but
you're standing
[Laughter]
yeah we actually had
[Laughter]
just a series of tubes be pretty cool
your dad's on a wheel
uh all right have you ever owned a bow
and arrow no
bb gun no paintball gun
no we had rubber band guns what
[Laughter]
were you a hacky sack guy no i tried to
yeah me too that was like yeah yeah that
was like an identity i tried on
yeah what kind of cars did your parents
drive uh
we had a ford taurus oh is that a
company car
what color one that was a choice
enough at school already making a wagon
folks
yeah that'd be chaos i was driving
around greenwich connecticut and what
color was it yeah it was a silver wagon
i know that torch wagon in a headgear
[Laughter]
came with a wedgie and then we had a
jeep we had a jeep
jeep not a wrangler like a chair the
real boxy one yes
all right or the grand cherokee had
things no we got a grand cherokee
we were a grand cherokee yeah see you
don't that's like that i don't know
yes it is they're nice was at least or
did you own it i think they leased it
yeah
at least maybe they i don't know have
you ever owned a hookah
yeah in college i got
i got like a smoke weed out of it yeah
okay
not too bad oh no no yeah no not tobacco
i see people sitting there on the
streets of new york smoking those things
i'm like you look like a [ __ ] they're
typically persian or something no that
if they're persian
the dominicans like it too it makes
sense but when you see like some [ __ ]
ding-dong
trying to look cool some white kid
trying to look cool smoking on the side
you gotta be a white kid
because that's what makes it look so
stupid i think it's kind of nice
yeah i didn't watch it it is it's one of
those things i was like who the [ __ ]
would and i think i've done it
i've done it once or twice and i was
like this is pretty good i get this very
flavored sweet
yeah guys just looking for an identity
it's a persian hacky sucker
i look at i look at a hookah like uh
like a non-alcoholic beer i'm just like
just smoke opie
yeah i don't get it yeah no i should get
a pack of bernie's in a six-pack call in
a [ __ ] day
[ __ ] am i doing here wasting everybody's
time go to the back room it's a chinese
theater and [ __ ] toke up with some
[ __ ] opium
[ __ ] do it right all right i got one
have you ever attended a birthday at a
hibachi restaurant
no been to benihana i don't think so
huh if you guys went out to dinner for
like a nice dinner
where would the o'connors go casual
dining
applebee's are you more like you know
antonios
damn i'm trying to think of last place
my friend who serves egg noodles
i don't know man i don't think dude
i don't i one time we went into the city
we went we got got paella
at like a place what man
my parents my parents they don't like
they don't they don't do
stuff they don't they don't like go out
and
they don't go out to dinner holy i can't
i ca i literally
cannot think of the last time what are
they doing their birthdays
or anniversaries something should they
ever go they never hug here
egg noodles they might yeah my dad my
dad likes chicken parm
and you kiss your dad when you like when
you like kiss like you give him a hug
what do you do i don't you don't hug
your dad that's my dad
we hug we hug it's like a thing you know
we gotta like build you know
we can't just be like hey man you know
yeah we got to do like ah
good to see you oh really double paddle
momentum yeah yeah you need to hit the
ramp with speed
[Laughter]
he's running down the street i don't
know if they're garbage they're
definitely oddballs they're definitely
irish this is very irish egg noodles
chicken farm don't go out turn the heat
down
don't hug you it's a lot that's yeah i
don't know there's all like those little
things that people always like i don't
know
people people that were like get would
get mad if someone didn't say goodbye
oh never understood real petty i never
understood that holding grudges
my parents were not like that at all
they'd just be like yeah you had to go
was there cousins up there around you or
was it just you guys
uh it was just uh no we had a we have a
couple cousins that uh
live club on my mom's side my dad
would my dad kind of my dad grew up in a
castle hill projects and my
mom grew up i think on sort of like the
nice part of the part of the bronx more
like
our avenue-ish kind of stuff um
so your dad comes from humble beginnings
yeah yeah all right
what about at christmas what their so
let's start with the tree
white lights colored lights what are we
doing uh it's been white lights for the
most part my brother was
my brother did not like real trees he
wanted a fake tree
the [ __ ] is that who gives a [ __ ] what
he wants i don't know who would listen
to that i don't know i just
like that's the other thing is nobody
cares about anything so he'd be like i
want a fake one
and everyone builds yeah everybody wants
a fake one no you know
that's [ __ ] scary man the o'connors
are fun
we've gone we've gone with like a real
tree for a while now we're in like
real tree mode but yeah nobody i don't
know just
nobody's again it's all little [ __ ]
they'll get pissed about like everyone
has their particulars about little
things
but most stuff it's just like whatever
yeah path of least resistance kind of
yeah like if you want to cut a piece of
wood in a certain way that's going to be
a fight
yeah yeah yeah but you know is there a
lot of wood cutting
yeah more than you'd expect yeah yeah i
don't know my dad
dad's always like building [ __ ] i built
like skate racks for a while
i worked for like a skateboard company
and built like on the wall like were
they like
uh these were like standing ones okay so
i got like a router and i was [ __ ]
building them we always like you know we
made like pinewood derby cars you guys
raised pinewood derby cars oh that was
always movie [ __ ] to us
wait what do you mean pinewood derby
what's that pinewood derby really
yeah what are you talking about it's
like a thing we did in the boy scouts
you guys in the boy scouts
no
[Laughter]
what did you guys do [ __ ] i don't
know ring and run smoking weed
i'm not hanging out with the other
people no well i did cub scouts i guess
i never made it to boy scouts
[Laughter]
did everything i could counselor didn't
want any pieces on me
um wait did you sit wait do you mean go
cars
it's the little car that you dropped
yeah you put like a certain amount of
weight on it yeah it's got to be under
32 kilograms and the wheels have to be
so yeah yeah
that's the one hey nerd alert
go get a [ __ ] basketball what do you
play little league [ __ ]
[ __ ] oh yeah we i did i did all that
too okay
football baseball cross
hockey i pegged you as a lacrosse hockey
wait a minute
you were able to afford hockey equipment
uh i did
a hand-me-down stuff so i'd have like i
liked playing goalie
okay and then my brother had a friend
who played goalie i got all his like
old stuff uh all right yeah was there
still a trip money transaction or
just giving uh i don't think so i think
he just uh i think he just gave it to me
because people
hockey unless you unless you live in
like [ __ ] ontario on a lake
hockey's a rich kid sports yeah yeah it
tends to no i mean it was it's like
expensive that's exposure yeah
the barrier to entry is higher i played
as well and it's like we used to dude
there was nothing better than street
hockey whether
oh dude the goalie had like the
catcher's mitt or something because he
had to like piece together the equipment
yeah so the ball goes down the gutter
yeah yeah you always had
a trash can or something in front of the
[ __ ] gun pennywise get you that's i
that like my uh i live in like sort of
there's like one driveway that we share
with two or three other houses
and like they paved it at one point like
at the height of our street hockey
and we were like this is the [ __ ]
yeah
and then and then they decided to put
this like fake
[ __ ] [ __ ] over it like stone okay
i don't know if you've ever seen this
like it's not gravel it's gravel that's
like glued to the
i kind of know what you mean yeah yeah
and it's like who wants this you're just
[ __ ] over
street hockey what the [ __ ] are you
doing that was like a big yeah my
brother and i lobbied hard
what are you guys [ __ ] doing uh the
shared driveway
yeah that's trash or it can be classy it
depends
wow no one's sharing a driveway
no gates ain't sharing a driveway with
anybody yeah
that's no bueno i don't know yeah it was
like a nice property split up yeah
which is typically cash oh
how long was it was it like it was like
a hundred private road
no no no all right yeah if it's a
private road and it splits off this way
and then it's puts off
they were like that's different yeah i
don't know
what about peeing in the shower yeah
which by the way we just talked about
this and then we used that clip to
promote last episode and my wife had no
idea i was peeing in the shower this
whole time
[Laughter]
she's like you pee in the shower i'm
like what no that's dumb i'm like babe
it's the bed i'm doing it
yeah why would they be upset well i
don't get what people i don't know but
it was just like she's like you
i honestly i thought everybody was doing
that yeah i didn't know people that were
not
and your girlfriend's german you think
she would be completely unfazed by piss
stuff
i know it's also like i don't pee she's
not why i think she's phased by it wait
why is that
they're into weird fetishes yeah are
they no lucky dog
also it's like it's like hippie wins
again and everything comes
you pee first it's not like the last
thing you do in there is piss
yeah it's also like the water's right
wash your hands with it yeah it's like
fresh
all right that's it for me ready to
start the day
you ever call anybody on facetime audio
i have done that yeah that's garbage why
why are you using uh you're using
facetime audio
just getting your [ __ ] [ __ ] there's
things that he doesn't understand fully
that you why would you call somebody on
facetime audio
uh well here's the here's the issue in
my neighborhood
uh because you have to be on wi-fi yeah
yeah
there's no service so you gotta plus
like i don't know
i have a buddy who uh who just like is
like
i don't know i was one of these people
gets upset about audio quality
and he's like the the facetime audio's
so much clearer it's like
oh stop hanging out with this guy yeah
who's that opinion
there's the audio who's on the phone
that long i don't know do me a favor get
a real christmas tree and stop talking
to this guy
yeah i'll tell you that right now all
that stuff yeah youtube comments
i don't know yeah he's rolling to reddit
too
um do you know how to tie a tie
i did i went through i went through a
phase where i was like i'm going to
figure out how to do this
what about a bow tie no i know i do know
how to tie a bow tie i heard how to type
this
son of a [ __ ] i i can send i've gotten
it before but
i can't do it yeah yeah it's too
frustrating that was another thing i
like i was like you know i'm gonna learn
how to do this
and i i learned it and it but then you
just forget so
fast because you're not doing it yeah
yeah i used to i when i worked at macy's
i had to do one every day and it was
like one of those things like i had i
think i had like my [ __ ] roommate or
my neighbor do it
and then like i just like left it on the
doorknob
like that you know and just kept using
it yeah yeah and at one point
i gotta learn how to do this what about
uh do you sleep with your mouth open
probably hmm this kid's a psycho
i'm big what i'm big mouth open yeah how
do you not
dude head back mouth open good night
catching
catching flies my family calls it i saw
you were out i came home you're on the
couch catching flies
i do grind teeth too oh man
connors are [ __ ] yeah wild type yeah
yeah yeah you guys
[ __ ] go do something go on vacation
or something does everybody drink coffee
in the house
uh yeah making the cavity yeah yeah
my dad's definitely one of those guys
who just like it doesn't understand iced
coffee
it'll be a hundred degrees outside and
he'll be like what are you [ __ ]
nuts it's like it tastes good it's the
same effect yeah no
my family's uh yeah my the the upper
breasts of my family are non-iced coffee
people
yeah just committed to dunkin donuts
coffee yeah
it's the weirdest thing because he's not
like an insecure dude either it's like
what what is
what is this thing that's your opinion
or something yeah yeah this is your like
helms deep get one of those foofy drinks
from stallbox or something that's what
all my family says
let me ask you this in your household
does your parents refer to the
channel number or the network like if
your mom said hey
put this on would she say hey channel
three put on channel three or put on nbc
it used to be that but now it's
different
it used to be like before the cable got
cute you know before you had like
everything six thousand channels and the
channels are moving it's like it used to
be like
you know mtv was channel 53. you know
channel 13 you know it's like it was pbs
or [ __ ] what they said
but now it's like my parents have the
full package you know
you know a million channels yeah i think
abc is on
805 or something like that they still
say put on six
yeah in philly it was three so we know
well put it on three it's either on
three six or ten
i don't know it's all deal it's gotta be
on three six or ten yeah they were
definitely big
uh channel people that yeah that was big
mm-hmm okay is that trash what's trash
here
if it's really channel eight hundred and
ninety four and yeah
are you guys clicker or remote clicker
yeah remote traffic
clicker clickers click yeah i said it's
because you're just doing
the the function of it you've renamed it
the function of it
yeah well that used to be the only thing
that it did call the phrase click up
yeah um yeah clicker's trash
i'm trying to think isn't it i heard it
i feel like i heard something
recently too but i can't pull it some
people yeah
there's another one floating around
there that's getting some headway
i'm trying to remember there's one that
like the way people talk about turning
the lights off
cut the lights off that's trash cut the
lights on or cut the lights off
it's trash yeah and another thing too
people that say i'm i was looking at the
get the tv out of my face you're either
watching it or you're not you're not
looking at it
looking at it means it's not on you're
[ __ ]
watching tv expecting it
get the [ __ ] out of it that's just [ __ ]
i'm looking at i'm like yeah i was
looking at the tv last night well we're
not talking anymore
um have you ever used the phrase it's
five o'clock somewhere
uh talking to the mic no no i haven't no
no
no my yeah my parents tea totalers too
not boozers
what's the tea totalers oh it's where
you don't drink wait tea
total i've never totally yeah what's
that mean i've never heard that just
drinks
i think it's an irish expression it's an
english expression it's so commonly used
sometimes you guys blow my [ __ ] minds
with the thing you don't know
teetotaler is one of the most standard
[ __ ] phrases yeah english lexicon let
me get toby a haircut all right
this guy's all hopped up yeah
yeah that's insane to me well i also
come from a family that does not
i no longer trust either one of you all
right they're both suspect in my book
what did you guys set up now i mean my
if you came over for a party and you're
like uh i'm a tee totally like
here's the exit go look at the tv they
would just say he doesn't drink
he doesn't drink and you would know
something [ __ ] up something's
happening yeah if you don't drink in my
family
everybody knows why you nobody just
chooses to not it was because of an
incident
yeah that it's like listen you can't
drink anymore i remember i was
drinking in the basement in my basement
with uh my buddies once
uh is there anything better than that
yeah just getting hammered in the
basement
i love it and uh my dad opened the door
he's like hey chrissy come up here for a
second
and i was like all right and i went up
there and said what are you guys
drinking down it smells like
he goes he smells like a [ __ ] brewery
down
and i was just hammered being like no
man what are you talking about
no we're not drinking he's like that
right yeah that was big though it was
always big when you were like my parents
we'll kind of we can't celebrate the
fact but we can kind of hide it
you know what i mean yeah yeah no
showboating
that's pretty showing off that's pretty
normal yeah yeah behavior
yeah all right that's it's not yeah it's
very yeah it's very
average was the basement finished no
so it's cement floor like area tile
but like but the laminate like what is
it a butcher shop
dude the o'connors were not big on
comfort i don't know
no no no it was functionality and price
over anything every page i turned you
keep surprising me
yeah dude the basement could be nice the
basement could be nice
but they don't they haven't done
anything with it did your mom read a lot
your mom a reader yeah she's like she
likes uh this is
[ __ ] she just reads through like um
she's a book of drugs and like what they
do like pharmaceutical
stuff and she looks to just reads
through them because she like you know
she interacts with old people a lot and
like
looks through like what medications
conflict with one another that's
she can just she can just churn on that
for 12 hours
what are you on benzos you gotta stay
awake
yeah that's yeah she found out that like
i have like what's the last do they go
to the movies or anything what the [ __ ]
who reads the [ __ ]
drugs they watch besides my friends from
high school yeah they they watch just
tv movies my uh my mom got into a show
she was like this show's so good i think
it was like the cop show with j.lo
she keeps trying to convince me to what
i don't even know what it's called it's
called like
blue or something blue bloods was big in
my house
big blue bloods yeah yeah she was like
oh it's the greatest show on and just
like i don't know have you watched
anything else
yeah no they haven't ever seen cheers
[Laughter]
watching [ __ ] info watching c-span
and [ __ ] holy
[ __ ] man yeah no they don't yeah they
didn't do any of that stuff
how do you feel about the rotisserie
chicken from the supermarket great
question love it would that be love
would that be on the menu at the
o'connor's house sometimes
that was like that that that started
happening in the late aughts
yeah dude same with thought my mom
brought one home with my headaches yeah
yeah yeah i was like we can just get
these yeah it's already cooked
look what i found yeah i mean the
whitest of white meat oh it's
so good it's so good i'm at the point
now in the show
where i'm not giving up i know i'm no
longer trying to like prove garbage and
i just want to see if you're
if if they're sane if they're normal
yeah they're all looking for normal
things that's why
yeah i got weird food [ __ ] like i i
started early when i would just eat the
frozen eggo waffles
eat them frozen yeah yeah just pull it
right out of the freezer frozen yeah
yeah yeah
i thought he meant like i would buy the
frozen ones cook them
is that legal i just take them out eat
them i eat like cold like i like cold i
was
no wonder why you grind your teeth this
guy's nuts
hey dexter cold water
cold lasagna love cold lasagna it's all
like
congealed and stuck i'll give you that
it's all right yeah [ __ ] i love it i
don't i barely i
like reheating something for me is like
why that's [ __ ] yeah why would you
enjoy the dish i'm with you guys
who's got three minutes for a waffle i'm
with you on that if it's the next day
and it was
i i know but i'll eat a cold hamburger
yeah that's fine
but a frozen waffle i'll eat cold that's
that's weird that's psychopath yes
that's psycho i don't know you gotta
toast it and put all kinds of man we're
talking minutes chris
90 seconds but
i always had a problem with i had a
problem with like i hated taking a piss
when i was a kid i couldn't take a piss
or take a [ __ ] like i just like because
i thought i would be missing something
that was like a big i would just hold
people back to are
[Laughter]
there's no doubt about it i don't know i
just like yeah
just like if i piss when i get back
everyone's going to be somewhere else
what yeah you said do you see a
therapist now no
you've now what talkspace.com who's the
sponsor
talk ahead no i don't i don't know i'm
scared to go take a pee
because i wasn't scared i just hated the
idea you know
because you thought if you thought it
would look like yeah you're like hanging
out with your friends and everything's
like
you're it's a good vibe to play mario
kart or whatever i don't want to [ __ ]
get up and take a piss and i
semi understand yeah i also enjoy on a
similar note i enjoy listening to the
radio
when a good song caught like that
because i go everybody's enjoying this
with me yeah yeah
if i'm listening to my cd it's just me
doing it it's lonely yeah
okay yeah that was a big problem you're
nuts
no i don't i don't know i don't i don't
think i i don't really like therapy i
don't think i tried it
apparently yeah i tried it but it just
never seems like the person's
like you need to interrogate me and
question everything that i'm saying for
this to feel like it's
working you know we're making some
progress right now
frankly honestly do you guys go to
therapy i have yeah
yeah it sucks when you're just like
you're telling a story about something
that happened
then you have to and the person's not
yeah you're kind of just looking at it
they got a pain you wonder if they're
gonna write down notes in their paper
they're like oh that's interesting as
opposed to being like they they really
said that
yeah you want some feedback yeah i mean
you're a comedian as well so you're
you're used to you want the you want the
interaction take my word
yeah i also like i hate the how does
that make you feel like
you tell me wait what do you mean like
the doctor will just take your word for
it
yeah yeah well if you tell them that a
situation happened a certain way they
just go like oh that's
you know it's like no criticize it try
to poke holes in it they're not gum
shoes what are you
doing they should be that's the whole
point it's like figure out if i'm lying
you know are you why are you lying no
well it's not it wouldn't be intentional
it'd be like am i
delusional you know i do there's so many
people who like
i go to therapy and they're like yeah
you know i found out like this is my
thing and it's like that's not your
problem
is that what you're working on do you go
in there with that
that's not even close to what your
problem is i'll tell you what your
problem is it's like one of those people
that's like yeah just like i
you know it's whatever it is give me a
specific example like what do you mean
like one of your friends told you what
and you think that their problems work i
had a buddy who's like uh
you know like someone was just like yeah
you know it's like i guess
my thing is like i just don't like hate
people and it's like what
you [ __ ] all you do is hate people
what are you talking about it'd be like
that kind of thing i also see what
you're saying it's like you don't have
to be genuinely on it like
someone who's like yeah you know my
thing is just like too much you could
paint yourself
yeah the most selfish [ __ ] piece of
[ __ ] i've ever met in my life what the
[ __ ]
you talking about there's nothing in
there that's what you're talking about
in there yeah
those therapists like maybe you're just
a jerk off phil yeah you know what i
mean
you're you're eating a frozen waffle
piss in your pants like you're pretty
[ __ ] up man
oh is that your problem steve you're
just too nice yeah
meanwhile you have bureau mice at isis
chris o'connor tough love therapy you're
a [ __ ]
well i've got myself a [ __ ] frozen
waffle and get over here i've dated
people too that are like you know
they're going to therapy
yeah and it's just like they're always
anytime they tell me about it i'm like
that's what you're
ugh this is never going to get fixed
because you guys are working on a fake
prop
yeah that's true this kid's hardcore you
currently are you dating anybody now
uh now just one second break up yeah i'm
sorry to hear that yeah that's all right
you currently own a gaming chair
i do not own a gaming chair but i just
got an oculus oh
we've seen the fate with the instagram
is that yours just so you know
i've seen them they're filming you
almost every time oh absolutely
absolutely this kid's amazing
swinging in his past
[ __ ] real crazy dude it is so much
one game
it looks like you're knifing somebody oh
it's called christmas this is your box
it's your boxing game here's your gift
dad
it's called leak house oh dude yeah no
that is the one recurring nightmare i
have is
is like trying to launch he's trying to
punch someone in the face and you can't
get him dude i've had him where i run
it's low self-esteem or confidence or
something i've had him where i'm like
running down the street and i know in my
dream that i go
hey you know this is a problem for you
really great you got to make sure you
connect
i gotta have a 500 yard running start
and i get up there and my hand just like
turns into a bullet
and it goes like behind me and i'm like
everything and then i get my ass kicked
i had a thing where i just i needed to
bash someone's like [ __ ] brains in
and i just couldn't
yeah i couldn't make it you just can't
you just like what did he do
i don't know i was probably trying to
kill me or something
i feel like you want to hit me right now
i'm trying to heat up my lasagna
i didn't get cold and i don't pee huh
yeah i don't know if you're garbage you
are
a bit bonkers yeah
how about how about this i try to shift
gears a little bit do you own an
american express
card no what kind of credit cards do you
have
uh i just have a one through bank of
america which is like travel rewards
okay does it have an airline on it no
i don't know yeah i don't know i didn't
learn any of the stuff that i should
have
learned financially yeah i don't know
growing up where i grew up
you know i've got no etiquette like
eating
what do you mean i don't know you mean
something you have something
specifically
i just feel like i don't there's just
chris you're in a safe place you know
we're gonna make fun of it for whatever
it is i don't know i just feel like
you know put a napkin and your napkin on
your lap always forget that
yeah okay you tuck it in the shirt no
okay
um i feel like i can chew with my mouth
open
i imagine there weren't a lot of salad
forks at the o'connors
no we would do salad okay we'd just do
romaine
chop it up you wouldn't have iceberg you
wouldn't have the forks lined up like
you know oh no no no no no
no no no no no no that's what i'm saying
i've never learned yeah never learned
any of that
[ __ ] yeah let me ask you this do you eat
cereal with a teaspoon or a tablespoon
tablespoon okay yeah all right or
whatever the big the big spoon
you don't know that oh wow are they is
that exactly a tablespoon i don't know
yeah that's weird
it's referred what about this do you
when there's shrimp that's like
fried with the tail on it you eat the
tail or no well hold on nobody answer
that question
what do you do i eat the tail this guy's
nuts
i eat the tail oh my god you don't i
also take a bite out of the whole
lobster toby call the police
when it's fried i wouldn't eat like if
it was like cocktail shrimp i wouldn't
eat the tail that's same shrimp
no when it's fried it's like it's it's
crunch is better
there is a dish salt and pepper shrimp
that they fry
with the shell on it and it's like in
pasta and then
what who's in pasta if you have
fried shrimp in a pasta dish or
something has that
that's right yeah no it should be served
as like an appetizer
shrimp what if you've never seen shrimp
with the tail on it in pasta
yeah not fried though fry you eat it
with the tail or you take the tail take
the tail off yeah
but you can't eat the [ __ ] he looked at
you
yeah we're crazy it's a mess am i nuts
what do you you can't eat the shell
of the shrimp if it's fried do you cut
wit you cut the tail off
no i pop it out with your hands i put it
in my mouth and pop it out
in a pasta dish sure i'll take the
shrimp out i see why is my crazy
sometimes i will cut that's not classier
eating it with your fingers is not
classic i'm not eating my tail like a
[ __ ]
like a [ __ ] seal it's a dirt ball
cash 22. yeah i don't know what the
answer is and i'm not a seafood kind of
guy so i don't i don't have i don't know
things are going well how old are you
when you first had lobster
was that like a new or i guess new
englandish kind i mean i don't know if
can i uh i i remember being like pretty
young it was like special obviously but
i remember like
um i remember my
i remember my dad like you know throwing
the lobster into a boiling pot
and being like did they does that hurt
them you'd be like nah
and then i remember like two years later
him being like uh
he'd be like oh yeah that [ __ ] him up i
don't think it does though no he was
like he was telling me about
when he was a kid they used to have like
they used to boil crabs
like at the beach and his job was to
knock them back in when they were trying
to climb out
yeah they scream no that's like that
they're not
no they they don't feel the fish so they
don't have a central nervous system
right they know what's going on no they
don't yeah they do they feel good they
feel pain
i don't think they don't yeah i think
they do no
i think they're not googling it right
now i think they do i don't think they
have a face that can wear an expression
of pain
but i think you [ __ ] saga yeah and they
don't have like lungs
lobster lobsters lack the brain anatomy
needed to feel pain
how would that be yeah how would the how
would they know to not get hurt in the
in the wild if someone somebody's
touching them yeah what
that doesn't make sense how would they
how would they know
it's the first thing that popped up
i don't know what's that from
lobsters.com
don't eat us.net
we feel this i swear to god knock it off
this [ __ ] hurts some republican lobster
think tank somewhere
holy [ __ ] chain-ling fence around the
house no
very nice now fence around the house
yeah i got a fence late got in high
school we got a fence
late yeah yeah yeah here's a big one
as of late on the podcast sprite
or seven up sprite
okay although growing up it was seven up
sure it was
yeah i can't get a [ __ ] read on you
people yeah seven it was mostly seven up
seven up
seven up but i'm a seven i'm a seven up
guy i would have thought you were more
crazy if you would have said seven up
just because you're younger yeah
so i don't know you don't see seven up
around anymore right muscle them out
yeah yeah
[ __ ] have you ever ordered girls going
wild
so okay never watched it no uh
maybe have you ever jerked off to the
commercial no neither keep it moving
fully no i i jerk i
yeah i jerked off we had a movie called
the getaway
what's that it was the nicole kidman or
with uh kim bassinger
yeah yeah yeah it's a remake yeah it's
really good yeah it is did you jerk off
to the jennifer tilly michael jackson
sex
yes yes so hot in that oh man i tell you
what i don't know how young you saw it
but that can [ __ ] you up because that
scene is [ __ ]
crazy i saw it recently jennifer tilly
did you jerk off though recently
no no no for old time's sake jennifer
it's dark jennifer tilly
works is married to this veterinarian
michael matson's an outlaw he gets hurt
he shows up to the veterinarian
makes the veterinarian fix him and then
somehow she falls in love with him
he's banging her while the
veterinarian's tied up in the bathroom
and he opens the door
and sees he's like what are you doing
it's then he hangs himself in the
bathroom yeah
i'm crazy yeah it's [ __ ] up and dark
and then when you're watching as a kid
jerking off you're like
[ __ ] that guy hey buddy yeah
more for us huh but now older you're
like oh
oh dude what a [ __ ] oh [ __ ] i'm gonna
have to rent that
it's really good yeah alex baldwin's
great in it so is james
yeah yeah it's a young alex baldwin yeah
it's when him and kim basinger were yeah
both very hot
that's it that that'd be a love scene i
wouldn't mind seeing yeah you ever seen
nine and a half weeks
yes yeah that's hot
that was yeah who's in that mickey
rourke
embassy wow yeah and it's just like it's
like softcore porn yeah yeah yeah
they just [ __ ] for nine and a half weeks
that's their whole that's pretty much it
yeah
sign me up strawberries any isuzus in
your family any isuzu cars
uh no my my good friend's mom had an
isuzu trooper
what if i wasn't a trooper yeah i liked
that car where did she strip
what about a saturn or a kia no
excellent okay all right now it's we've
got an acura
oh you got astronauts who was an acura
uh my mom had an act or my dad had an
acura for a while
wow yeah what is it new car people are
pre-owned
uh that was a new car yeah when did the
tourists come into the family the taurus
was 1985
through 1985 yeah through 2003
2002. yeah had a long run damn that ran
for 18 years that's [ __ ]
crazy yeah it was a ford motor company
yeah
doing it right yeah that car was [ __ ]
up
ever use the facebook story feature no
have you ever worn jenko jeans no
never wanted them really yeah i always i
was like that is [ __ ]
dumb i got lead pipes [ __ ] [ __ ] ass
[ __ ]
oh man i remember this looking back
thank you mom for only getting me lee
pipes but
i remember as a kid thinking like not
wanting to get into any 90s style
because i looked at the way people
looked at themselves from the 80s
and how they were like look how [ __ ]
stupid we looked and i was like well i
don't want to do that i don't want to do
that you don't want to look back
who has that perspective though that's
crazy yeah so how old are you
how old am i yeah 35 pretty good
you he could be a serial killer i don't
think so
the way you said that's exactly what a
serial number is i don't want to blend
in
no i'm not very i'm not violent move to
the woods
yeah yeah i just want to move to just
want to move to the woods and draw that
body
i'm getting drifter serial killer no
no i could never i can't even punch
people in the face in my dreams
without peeing has any member of your
family
ever any male member of your family ever
not had sideburns like where they
purposely
cut the sideburns no no white walls
white walls
white walnuts yeah white wall what's the
deal with that yeah that was a 90s
nobody nobody looked crazier
than the dude walking around with no
sideburns i
saw i i was watching the sixers play the
other night i swear to god there's a guy
on the other team oh no
it was it wasn't the sixers at all it
was a [ __ ] soccer game
there was a dude with white walls it's
like what the [ __ ] are you doing dude
that shit's weird man what what is that
that dude that was like
dude that in the 90s with like a red
tank top tucked into a pair of jean
shorts
that was like the uncle uniform dude go
over your buddy's house that guy what's
up i'm uncle steven
yeah what are they thinking yeah have
you ever had anyone explain what that is
no i don't think i've ever really like
had someone
if somebody was closing i would [ __ ]
say something i'd like to what are you
doing
it's crazy i've never had someone that
close to me hmm
what yeah there was no sideburns you're
out there and you have no sideburns
get out of the country all right let's
do uh let's do some of the patreon
questions real quick
absolutely get it out of here guys
obviously uh when you sign up for the uh
patreon we will read one of your patreon
questions
one of your garbage questions it's the
best way to do it we get hit up with so
many questions that this is kind of the
best uh the best way to do it fun times
over there uh so this was from george
zak actually the guy who painted the new
mural in the world wow
love you george [ __ ] dope gorgeous
shout out to george he says have you
ever chewed gum instead of brushing your
teeth
yeah yeah i did it this week yeah yeah
yeah yeah
for sure i was home i got home i got to
my parents on sunday
i brushed my teeth for the first time
this morning
yeah that's yeah and showered for the
first time this morning how are you
doing cavity was
it's funny you mentioned that on the way
up here i was kind of like grinding my
teeth and i felt a little
sting i'm missing two teeth when was the
last time you were at the dentist
uh i had to go this year
uh a year probably a year before that
that's not bad you go every year uh i've
been doing pretty good
past couple of years yeah out of pocket
uh i had dental insurance for a while
but now but i got a buddy who's who like
owns a
thing so they did some work for free
yeah dental a dental office
yeah okay a dental dam yeah huh not like
uh
how long you're going on a while oh i
was a decade and i went last year
right how'd you do pretty good i was
just kind of like yes
any cavities no no which i thought i was
like i'm gonna get hemmed up for at
least a couple
but i got some two years ago i got like
some cavities filled
and then i one of those like one of
those fillings
fell out and they were like we should
probably just put like a fake tooth in
there oh that's my atmosphere
yeah got a crown yeah you're also
missing a bunch back then i'm missing a
bunch i'm missing
three three teeth totally that's a bunch
can we not say that three's a bunch of
teams
that's a lot you know what we're saying
people three three is a bunch of your
teeth you said it was
two not thirty seconds ago yeah yeah he
lies
yeah he lies about everything yeah it's
minimum four
and he's telling us three i have no
teeth
um yeah you got to get that you got to
get that fixed because i think i think
you're
i think you're like the bone actually
starts to like nah i'm 45.
i'm cruising you look great
i'm a year and a half away from i'm i'm
two years away from veneers anyway
yeah patreon.com that's the first thing
i'm doing i get my health fully get
veneers sign up patreon.com
i'm getting assistance i'll even kick in
a little bit of mine and we'll get you
like a [ __ ]
proper set of champions wait your teeth
[Laughter]
um nice teeth are they hippies yes they
are this is all right next one this is
from this is a shout out to one of the
historians people this is carlin i'm
polish but my sausage is more like a
cooked breadfish link uh
nice yeah hans um have you ever used the
bathroom scallop at someone else's house
which i have for sure done yeah yeah
yeah but not like it was out right you
didn't like take it out
yeah it wasn't like rooting through the
closet yeah it was like sitting there
and i'm like oh i'm gonna [ __ ] well i
don't have to maybe do a before and
after you know what i mean
i don't have oh yeah take a [ __ ] see how
much weight you lose that's nice well
you take a peek through the medicine
cabinet at somebody else's house
look no no no cause i don't i don't
really even know
what any of that is i'm snooping really
what do you hope to find
i'll take anything it doesn't matter
really i'll take
dog's medic whatever's in there i'll
take i've never uh i've never taken any
like
prescription [ __ ] like that hmm got a
good head on his shoulder yeah good head
on his shoulder on his nice shoulders
he's got to stay focused when he's
murdering people
that's kid's a weirdo yeah yeah yeah
i've always wanted to
but i never yeah it's not for me yeah
what
i don't know just take like yeah never
taken like valium or anything like that
or like
i don't know whatever hey studio
whatever people do that's what i'm
saying i like
if i open up a medicine cabinet i would
just see a bunch of words i don't know
talk to your mom she knows that the oh
my god she got the encyclopedia
oh no yeah she wrote the book on them i
got my wisdom teeth out
in high school and she was so worried
about me she
she like wouldn't let them give me any
drugs for it yeah and they were all like
impacted it was [ __ ] miserable oh
dang cause she didn't want to get hooked
yeah yeah smart smart lady she's
probably right yeah she has the right so
i had a bunny that went in for like to
get his tonsils out like when he was
even as like a as an adult they were
like infected or something you gotta get
your tonsils out then like literally
six he had never done drugs and like six
weeks later he's shooting around
what yeah he's now skeptical holy [ __ ]
like literally like he would only he
wouldn't even drink
because we were all getting [ __ ] up
and he was like so paranoid he's like
yeah i don't drink hard liquor i only
drink coors light because he was like
afraid of what like rum would do to him
and then literally like weeks later he
was [ __ ] shooting up h
right that's crazy yeah my
my like i feel like that i don't know my
generation sort of
generation i don't know just the kids in
my class in like high school we like
missed that
oh that was so no see we were saying
yeah what do you mean you guys should
have been dude kids stealing [ __ ]
oxies like crazy yeah it was like two or
three years below us
was when that was like big there was not
a whole lot of like
coke and [ __ ] when i was in high school
it was all just like weed and booze
and then shout out to the good times
yeah yeah that's the good stuff right
there yeah but
eddie have a glass of wine good night
yeah those kids got into it hard
there's like yeah there's a lot of kids
like in a couple years behind us there's
like they got they got mowed down
friends of mine that that i went to when
i graduated with that i know
listen to the show we're all [ __ ]
oxyheads
none of them got in trouble too right
they basically just no a lot of oh
who the sacklers yeah they they got
their name taken off like the [ __ ] out
of like lincoln center or something but
nobody's in the joint nobody's doing
that they're
good they're they'll get out of it but
there was a bunch of emails that like
they found out that they buried and
stuff
oh yeah like reports yeah the [ __ ] that
they've admitted that
is fraudulent i don't know if they'll
ever do time but that's the thing is if
you have a hundreds of billions of
dollars
you're never going to go to jail we'll
do like house arrest or something yeah
yeah
yeah people will be like we'll just pay
this big
fine yeah you know it's like
yeah right you're gonna have to spend a
fortune just trying to get them in jail
and they'll keep like they can appeal
but yeah yeah yeah that's why old rich
guys never
they always like no matter how evil they
are they always die
before they go to prison you know what i
mean yeah they can just keep drawing it
out yeah yeah they'll just keep
appealing and fighting it and they wind
up in some like
halfway thing yeah sort of one foot in
one foot out that's why they call it a
debt to society they're like we'll cover
yeah we got it all right last one here
this is from ryan jacobs
growing up would you purchase a book
cover for school textbooks or did you
use the brown paper grocery bag
brown paper grocery bag
oh man the first couple days of school
having my mom
my mom did that so well i remember like
when i first had to start doing it
myself i'm like [ __ ] that what am i
doing no way
yeah that was just like another thing
that the girls did so much better
cooking cleaning yeah just handwriting
yeah girls always have better penmanship
man they really do
and you could tell any guy with good
handwriting like that was
writing notes and being a [ __ ] do you
love me
yeah yeah i like i i have one friend who
writes in that bubbly uh
and i was just like you're passing notes
around like this
i was just a supervisor yeah really
i guess is extra i mean in junior high a
lot of kids had phones
really wait there was text messages for
you in junior high
i think like eighth or ninth grade is
when they hit yeah holy [ __ ] i don't
think i ever wrote a note
it's like i could barely do my homework
i'm not
writing essays how can i write a letter
before
[Laughter]
i have a new one that i wanted to do how
would you hold a pencil uh this like
this
regular okay yeah yeah yeah why some
people go this way some p well i don't
know this is a new thing that i want
on the show you get some real dirtball
grimy [ __ ]
which it's like i can't respect you if
you write but you know what i actually
think that this is like this is an
endurance position
you can write like this forever that
writing like this
you're like this knuckle starts no guys
signing checks like this
okay yeah yeah no way signing anything
yeah
that's creepy some people do this one
yeah that's what i want to get
i want to start asking all the guests
how they hold a pencil my one cousin
writes like that yeah that's
crazy right you're how do you hold
you're a little tricky
i hold it like this no no i hold it like
this
yeah like it's [ __ ] gentle yeah okay
thank god you're not left-handed i
thought for sure you'd be left-handed no
no no
this is crazy this is just the most
that's nuts
yeah that's bananas i mean i don't
understand who taught those people
how to hold a pencil i don't know i
think it's just they're like like
they've never done anything
this is kind of people just like they're
bumping into [ __ ] they're breaking stuff
this is clumsy as [ __ ] i hold the pen
good but one thing i have
is uh i hold pen
[Laughter]
when i used to write like if i had to
write like a paragraph
by the time i got to the bottom it would
it would be crooked
the whole oh yeah crooked like i
couldn't like use each line
it would eventually get down to like
where it would just be like three lines
over here
like right on an angle yeah yeah it
would go
it was like learning center it would
like fan out yeah
bad news i mean i don't know i don't
know all right let's
make a [ __ ] i don't know he's crazy
clearly
definitely crazy a lot of emotional
issues i've picked up so i think i'm
pretty limited
you're crazy i'm not i would say there's
a lot going on
i would say he's kind of garbage yeah
definitely yeah
yeah you're trash trash that's nice
in weird ways trash yeah it's upsetting
and this is this is because i'm right on
the line yeah some things you know i
don't see it
wouldn't even say that trash
trashy people would think you're stuck
up yes or something like that
classy people think it would think i'm
trash yeah hmm
yeah i mean so it's yeah it's a real
tonight we'll be having
a lasagna oh can i have a cold can you
drink mine
yeah we would do we like uh day old
lasagna wait hold on would the whole
family like it cold
no but a day old of course heat it up
no no well yeah but they liked it to
make it let it sit
in the fridge for a day to like come
together and then eat it they're like a
leftover-ish kind of thing
we'll see you next made the black yeah
same with cake
make a cake the day before let it sit
for a day
eat it literally what
i don't understand that i'm talking
about that's crazy so your mom would
make dinner
your mom wouldn't don't look at that
till tomorrow yeah yeah yeah your mom
would make
your mom tuesday night you come home
from school hey mom what are you doing
hey chris i'm making lasagna great when
are we having it next thursday
okay yeah that's what you're telling me
yeah and it would be like
my dad's birthday was or your birthday
was a couple days away my mom would be
like making a cake that would just be in
the fridge
until their birthday wait what why
just i don't know i do something like i
don't know mike wait did you think it
tasted my dad
what i don't know my dad always had like
a weird like he wouldn't eat
strawberries because there's too many
seeds
he's like go and i remember being i
never even
knew there were seeds i didn't even
notice the seeds who gets angry at
strawberries
yeah that's [ __ ] he did like weird
things and like those guys
he's staying in new jersey this guy this
guy needs a vacation yeah that was
always just
he had just like weird tastes like that
it's like make the cake a couple day i
like the leftover cake
yeah that's i mean that's banana i don't
even know what to say
because i know what happens to a
homemade cake
with like betty crocker icing in the
refrigerator
yeah and it ain't good no yeah it is it
gets like kind of wet
and crusty a little bit you know that's
how i love my cake white and crusty
folks
can i interest you with a dessert yeah
what do you have that's old
how many day olds laying around yeah go
get the old bagels and [ __ ]
yeah dude that's bananas yeah i like
that
holy [ __ ] i don't i don't the thing with
the lasagna man that's like [ __ ]
that's whack-a-doo yeah i used to yeah i
like
when i was living in philly i would like
i would order
like for delivery i would just get like
three cheese sticks you bring it next
week
you know to eat them over the next
couple days and i would i would just eat
cold
i've done that for the cheesecakes like
oh i like the cold
didn't yeah the next day yeah but he
would order out for multiple days he's
saying
yeah i mean if you're ordering your
cheesesteak on friday for monday
you're grocery shopping at pizza places
that's what you're doing puts it in the
cupboard
i'm going to put it in an order yeah
give me 12 cheesesteaks
party over there huh no it's just me i'm
trying to think
yeah i like i even like just a pasta
dish
that has like a like just a vodka sauce
if it's all cold and
just frozen together i like that you've
had it warm right
yeah okay man yeah
like sandwiches i just i think i like
when it's all stuck together i see what
you're saying yeah yeah yeah
like sandwiches i don't know it's more
contained yeah once i bite into a
sandwich i can't put it down
i'm very yeah it's like if i do put it
down i gotta like place it like yeah
yeah yeah if it all falls
i just started getting cold chicken and
dude it's way i'm like i could hear i'm
like why don't i heat this up what are
you talking about it's just
contained it's all together it's like
super glue folks if you see this guy
coming down the street
[Laughter]
run yeah you guys [ __ ] full-blown
psycho
chris o'connor is there anything you
want the folks out there to know
uh oh we're gonna be when is this coming
out is this coming out
like plug stuff not like where the
bodies are buried
i don't know what you're about to do
it'll be uh it'll uh it'll be out on
youtube tonight it'll be out tonight and
tomorrow so you can watch this weekend
yeah yeah yeah
weekend yeah i'll be at good nights in
raleigh with uh shane gillis
nice weekend it'll be a hot one cool um
yeah i think i don't know probably a
couple more dates coming up but i don't
know exactly when
absolutely fantastic and then yeah check
out tires if you haven't seen it
amazing amazing and uh yes the show
brood
a little cartoon i'm making and that's
it yeah that's good what's your patreon
uh it's i think patreon.com
the show brood very nice check it out
very funny
very interesting episode yeah yeah i'm
sorry i couldn't i
feel like i scared you guys i couldn't
bummed you out yeah yeah
yeah i'm more afraid i'm gonna be laying
in bed thinking about cold cake tomorrow
i'm more afraid of you now than i was
before
and i think i was a little afraid of you
to be honest so
all right got nothing nothing to fear so
stoic
nothing to fear this cold dead eyes just
let it go
holy [ __ ] kippy what do you got for that
uh guys as always please make sure you
view subscribe on itunes full video
available on youtube patreon.com you can
get all the bonus content the live
streams you know
[ __ ] the tour of foley's house is up
there oh yeah foleyville
the tour of foley's childhood house is
up there mine's coming up soon as well
as the car
yeah and uh the new goal we just added
at 800 patrons
we're gonna do a [ __ ] the honeymoon
suite at the pocono pal or what's it
called the pleasure dome something
uh with the champagne [ __ ] hot tub
gonorrhea resort in hotels it's gonna be
a good time
check it out wait what i mean fully
gonna [ __ ] from patreon
i gotta get those numbers up you know
what i mean gang we love you we'll see
you next week
chris thank you thank you kippy i love
you good night thank you
gang don't miss the ru garbage after
party over there on stereo app
every thursday night at nine o'clock
uncle hank and and kippy are answering
your questions you're having a good time
over there
ain't we kip yeah it's good we get to
mix it up with you guys uh it's like the
show but a little
you know a little more interactive you
guys get to ask your questions we take
them live you get to record them it's a
good time you got to get involved i
don't know what you're waiting for
super fun audio quality is fantastic you
can sign up for free
on android or iphone download it
follow kippy follow me it's a great time
yeah we're gonna be going live every
thursday get involved